we haven't talked about any press
briefings by joe biden's white house
press secretary jenn
saki for a bit we've been tied up with
other things like
coveted stimulus and much more but i
want to look at one today
because it's quite interesting what's
going on first of all
this first clip is cbs reporter ouija
zhang asking jensaki to respond to
claims that joe biden has opened the
border wide open and people are just
pouring pouring in
and it wasn't happening under donald
trump but it is now now it's really
important to remember
that even though donald trump didn't
build the wall during his presidency
he would regularly claim that he built
it
and that the imaginary wall was
responsible for record
low undocumented crossings now bear with
me because this requires
assuming multiple lies are true to
understand their
position if you believe trump that he
built the wall
and of course if you believe that joe
biden hasn't taken down that wall
you would have to imagine that the job
that the wall was doing at keeping
people out
when trump was president is still
keeping people out today
but the narrative has shifted into biden
has opened the border and people with
diseases are pouring in
the nazi rhetoric that we talked about
earlier
and here gensake smartly goes after the
idea of americans are saying
and gets reporter ouija zhang to admit
well i mean trump trump is the one
saying it and gensake quickly dispenses
with the nonsense
but a lot of americans are saying that
you know
the surges are happening under president
biden's watch
after he reversed some previous policies
so
does the administration take any
accountability for
what's happening who are the americans
well
i know you don't want to answer to him
but the former president just
um released a statement saying that uh
the biden administration was acted
immediately to end the border nightmare
that they have unleashed on tarmac
former president trump
yes we don't take our advice or counsel
from former president trump on
immigration policy which was
not only inhumane but ineffective
over the last four years we're going to
chart our own path forward and that
includes treating children with humanity
and respect and ensuring they're safe
when they cross our borders
this is just so funny and i'm not even
really looking to criticize
wija zhang i think that she's asking
what are meant to be tough questions she
asks them of kaylee mcinanni
she asks them of gen saki it's more a
lesson in how vapid and politically
biased these claims
are where from trump's last day
to biden's tenth day republicans started
wildly claiming joe biden has opened the
border wide open
joe biden has dramatically changed
what's going on at the border when in
fact
if there's a real critique of joe biden
here it's that he hasn't changed that
much about what's going on at the border
since taking over despite promises to do
so we talked about that early last week
i won't
rehash the entire conversation just a
few
more funny examples of hijinks at the
latest press briefing
here's a reporter asking why joe biden
hasn't done a solo press briefing yet so
we're 45 days into the biting presidency
and he has yet to hold oppressor
at this point in past presidencies every
president
you know from reagan had addressed
reporters some of them multiple times
so why the delay and when can we expect
the presidential holder press conference
well first as all of you know the
president takes questions several times
a week
he took questions actually twice
yesterday which
is an opportunity for the people
covering the white house to ask him
about whatever news is happening on any
given day
we look forward to holding a full press
conference in the coming weeks before
the end of the month
and we're working on setting a final
date for that and as soon as we do we
will let you all know
i can really kind of see both sides on
this i mean
certainly presidents should be taking
questions from the press
it is true that while you usually see
both the president and their press
secretary taking questions in the press
briefing room
biden hasn't done that yet but biden is
holding
covid related and other events almost
daily and he doesn't take questions at
all of them but he's taken questions a
whole bunch of times in his first six
weeks in office
sometimes as jen saki points out more
than once in a day okay
i mean the point is that the press in
the midst of what is at least for now a
very popular presidency all things
considered
biden again highest initial approval of
any president in 30 years almost
70 cove relief support etc
the press are having to sort of
manufacture problems or scandals
and it's not going super well i think
that there are plenty of fair critiques
they could go after but they're going
after other things
one other example fox news reporter
stepping away briefly
from the dr seuss scandal which has been
24 7 on fox news for about a week now
to push this crisis at the border thing
and i think what jen saki
does well here she doesn't do everything
well but this she did well
she refuses to escalate into the
hysterical language that the reporter
from fox is baiting her with take a look
are there any discussions within the
white house about
reversing the policy of allowing all
unaccompanied children
in the united states no not at all
so i i guess is the plan then to
take in and safely and humanely find a
home
for an unlimited number of unaccompanied
children
i think this issue requires us taking a
step back as human beings
um and as mothers of which i am one i
know there are many
in the room or many at home um these
kids are coming they are fleeing
prosecution
they are fleeing difficult circumstances
in their home country
uh when they come here all we're talking
about here is ensuring that they are
treated
safely they are not trafficked they are
not sent back
on a unsafe journey that's what we're
talking about when they come
when these kids come in it doesn't mean
they are insured that they get to stay
they go through the processing system
that everyone goes through but we want
to ensure that that is done
uh by treating them humanely and and
with respect
many of them will be sent back home
eventually but we're talking about
uh how we treat them as they come in the
country now i have been critical of joe
biden
on immigration i think his one executive
order on stopping removals which was
stopped by a judge
wasn't enough he should have done
another one using a different different
legal rationale i talked about that last
monday but the hysterical critique that
policy has dramatically changed in six
weeks
resulting in people just now pouring in
uncontrollably
it's silly the projection that the fox
news reporter cites about 110
000 or whatever that number was we had
similar
projections under trump the point is
under trump what they're counting on
is that under trump nobody who watches
fox knew
that these are just the normal numbers
that immigration authorities are dealing
with
so when the fox news reporter there says
the the expectation is 110 000
kids will come it sounds shocking but
there's nothing particularly notable
about those numbers
this is a huge country and those are the
same numbers we were seeing
under donald trump so we'll see
if and how the tone and tenor of the
briefings change over time
for now this is what it's been like and
gensake handling it
relatively well you may not have known
this but when you see me
sitting here on the show i am often
wearing shirts by a company called teddy
stratford i asked them to be a sponsor
because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that it
looks really good
and just all around they cut the entire
shirt in a specific way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with
100 egyptian cotton and flat-felled
seams which means it's going to be a lot
more durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout